quite frankly I'm tired of seeing white
women taking up all of the space in a
movement that was inherently black and
indigenous my name is Dominic Drake Ford
and I work very diligently to be zero
waste ish some exciting things that I do
on a day-to-day would be carrying my
mason jar my water bottle I bring my own
tote bag whenever I need to go grocery
shopping I try to reduce single-use
plastic I try to use tin and glass as
much as possible in my home I just
started my first backyard garden so I'm
growing my own food I have my own
compost bin so I'm composting waste
that's in the home I DIY as much as I
can I upcycle and repurpose clothing
when I can I vintage shop thrift shop
sometimes I make my own house cleaning
products sometimes I make my own skin
care and hair products and one of my
favorite things to do is make my own
toothpaste and another way that I really
work to be sustainable on a day-to-day
is showing that on my insta stories my
sustainability journeys didn't happen
until I moved to New York and I was
attending this colloquium and it was
about sustainability and
environmentalism and I really looked and
saw that there was nobody nobody who
looked like me and the only person I saw
that looked remotely like me was a
laborer being shown on a screen and so I
was like you know what I'm not with this
this is where a shift needs to happen
and this is where I need to develop a
voice so that we can create change in
terms of formal education I have my
bachelor's degree in business
environmental management and then I have
my master's degree in sustainable
entrepreneurship in fashion growing up
in Oakland I definitely had access to
nature and so that was where my first
love was sort of cultivated one of the
reasons why I refrain from wearing the
zero waste title the zero waste movement
felt very exclusive it had sort of a
privileged veil over it and the
conversations that were taking place in
the zero-waste community never paid
homage to black and indigenous cultures
who sort of created that mandala to be
zero ways or to be resourceful being
resourceful has been something that
communities of color have had to do for
generations and so being able to take
that first step to shift our
understanding it's super important so I
want to see more black and indigenous
people being highlighted in the
zero-waste community quite frankly I'm
tired of seeing white women taking up
all of the space in a movement that was
inherently black and indigenous and the
environmental crisis is
disproportionately affecting black and
indigenous people despite the fact that
they've had these zero-waste manifestos
always I am the co-creator of an
initiative called sustainable Brooklyn
which bridges the gap between the
sustainability movement and targeted
communities we are two black women who
came together realizing that number one
we were tired of the narrative of
sustainability again being white driven
but also we were tired of going to the
sustainability events and not being
represented in the audience not being
represented on the panel not being
represented as models not being
represented in creative direction and
most importantly sustainability not
discussing solutions for black and
indigenous communities on the ground
we're able to create events and provide
resources and discuss sustainability
mainly fashion food and wellness but
discuss it from such a holistic approach
in a way that has never been done before
our last symposium is called Earth Hour
next symposium is called air and air is
gonna obviously focus on air quality but
also really look at the mental health
aspect of breathing and breath work and
then fire and water are going to take
place in 2020
so we're super excited to be able to
have this elemental series that's going
to transcend how we look and understand
and sort of activate on sustainability
my baby is melanin s and the S stands
for and sustainable style melanin s is a
digital space that celebrates a black
and indigenous communities of color in
fashion food wellness and land
sovereignty and it's a unique space
where I'm able to interview all of these
different trailblazers all of these
different vanguards from around the
globe who either have a brand have a
business or they have an awesome
sustainability initiative I think now
more than ever it's imperative for us to
redefine sustainability and give it a
very clear historical context but also
make sure we're including a very
authentic cultural lens to that mix and
really making sure that we are giving
agency and stakeholder ship to black and
indigenous communities if we really want
to have a sustainability movement
[Music]